good evening everyone and welcome at
least the sun's coming out for us this
evening rather than the right so that's
good can we take the emergency
evacuation announcement the train
schedule for all we know where we know
the exits are etc apologies for absence
I don't think there are any non members
attending and I think they're already
minutes of the meeting on the second of
March is it your wish I silent as a few
record great thank you any declarations
of interest what if anything should come
up during the meeting please declare it
then we'll make sure it goes in the
vinings so we're straight to its charlie
oh yeah whether we need to declare
because we live following duty weapon
with regard to the item driveway
cleaning refuge amenities to the boat
there isn't a need for that i would say
will be a common interest Julia's
conference also thank you for bringing
that up it's right there that's Olivia
as long as our advice is the same as a
that's why I thank you right so item
five in which is a report from a review
committee relating to planning
enforcement I don't know if you want to
speak to this to me anymore right you
guys chamber of always very clear yes
indeed yes it made some recommendations
and we've actually responded to those
recommendations in a report which has
been made available to all members so
I've been able to have a look as a draft
example of what we're looking at doing
going forward the main thrust of the new
committee or part of that fast we'll
have a mother was to have a quarterly
report but but looking at it
that it is far better to do a long going
mum presumably so members are kept up to
date an ongoing fashion and it will help
them to understand exactly the position
as it goes on with regard to how
enforcement or managing with the new
triage system that's been voting and
basically is pretty self-explanatory
what they're doing at the moment and how
they going forward and i would recommend
but this is actually put forward as as
an ongoing thing for future reference ok
so this customer is any group or what
she says three months doesn't it for you
say so I'm recommending one month I
think that that the quarterly may be too
onerous and I would rather see something
coming forward on a monthly basis can i
embed please Elliot the recommendation
will review it is a report that's
presented to full council yes clearly
that's not a practicality when it comes
to nothing this report be a monthly so
your recommendation I presume is that it
would just be included in a monthly
report to members as part of our normal
check some system for nothing are
correct yeah yes I think that's our
second group thank you very much you're
more than life ok did you want speak my
oh so I thought you deleted ok but I
think as far as that's concerned that's
fine so as far as the recommendations of
concern let's see if we look at page
with its 5.6 just
lunch and a 5-10 of the page and sell by
the way or 10 / 0 point other 3.3 other
page 5.2 so you've got two
recommendation there that one's about
the joint protocol I think we had a
joint one or more oh sorry yep miss that
somewhere then yeah that's a summary you
look to their I say yeah other two yeah
right so yeah under 2 on page five point
one you've got the various items there
and see if a quarter report so we'll
make that a monthly report for members
yeah and chairman can you just go back
one there because the first item it is a
joint enforcement protocol yeah not on
that bit lower now and the
recommendation fire too yeah that's
coming up later how's it yeah but my
shakes its before it so what place
you're looking on five by one you can't
be an RDC issue ipad well that's what it
is it said ipad yes this is the final
report directly that mr. ec quarter
report I've got 5 10 and it
recommendation is under paragraph 5 from
my uncle chairman of active enemies I
survival H 5.1 recommendations yeah
thank each 5.2 has further to
recommendations fugitivo chairman I look
at regulation what are there to use well
the what we've got here is the report of
the review committee into this body at
the very front on page 5.1 and 5.2
too we've got a synopsis of the
recommendation later in the main report
so that's their riparian area from ready
so they're all the same but we pay to
5.1 or 5.2 is just isolate the
recommendations so ideally i think 5.1
in that it was the review more generally
a planning enforcement that came first
and from what I'm sensing there's a
monthly report to members on planning
enforcement in general possibly by the
bulletin is where i get its where
members are around with the second
recommendations on page five point two
they emanate from the michigan's form
yep report yep and they're the ones that
may need to be about some discussion on
from from members the first one being
about the joint important process all
yeah but i think there was general
agreement think they already have a
powerful thing you know we're fun
previously hadn't protocols but stream
the world's council were honored by the
report kind of organization applause but
we're the legal team of the year i
believe us and this is a joint
prosecution and essex county council DN
ourselves so it's an established
situation yeah i don't think we need to
do more than that we're top of the tree
with that regard we are awaiting the
decision from our legal department as to
what further action is necessary and i
don't think we need to do any more net
other than wait for that information my
recommendation adventures enlarged as
though they're there is very very good
communications now being established
between all parties in regards to any
breaches that may happen so i think it's
a case that if they're going to take out
are we talking with each other to ensure
that they're working together and
they're not out of kilter with each
other which has been the problem
previously okay fine so clearly the
lines of communication is very much over
I have to do our information is flowing
I don't think it's been a problem I know
that's why they were they receive the
reward division yeah absolutely because
clearly they did work hand in glove this
and other data stream the world okay but
what the Dickens you do with a fellow
that ends up in prison for six months as
then comes out and carries on heaven
only nurse hanging as i pointed out
monday perhaps bring back capital
punishment that bashar permanently if
it's a German economic others please
perhaps what I want to clear out the
issue here and the recommendations are
on five team yes weird like to see a
painting its beef yeah troop is a
separate issue of teeth because the
symmetry there hello there would be s
well that's why I'm showing to it too
gender all together on on white one
factors yeah on page 51 or 52 that bring
date those two pages bring out the
recommendations at a part of the bigger
report that is attached so it allows
members to focus on the actual
recommendations they are the same
okay I'll try to work out whether they
still cut the same rooms they do yes so
the recommendations that we should be
following are on tight end Amaro well i
think i've recommended 5.2 yeah i was it
yeah okay you'll find them cook the same
we won't find on the same down possibly
five Tambor put five to death that's
weather ok so again starting them from
where I was on 52 51 sorry for I was
married before so so we're looking a 2.1
that members receive a monthly report on
outstanding enforcement cases with the
detail that's listed there and
performance indicating enforcement are
revisited to ensure they reflect current
circumstances and practice to terminally
sorry I don't want to claim the issue I
I think you'll find that the information
that's in the suggested monthly report
doesn't match exactly the list of bullet
points and so therefore I'd suggested
the resolution needs to be in relation
to the ocean information that's in the
other one I guess that can be attached
to the ninja or something all these
little bit goes without an image here
yeah okay so as long as that I'm sorry
with that the okay and please show you
you know although going back 25 team
yeah i'll still try to be
so just wait 5 11 yeah there are some
other items for example 3 they request
further place to stash the pie so the
energy two items to the second day I
hope you come back soon amici yes okay
it's not being said it's nothing to its
roots the committee's 5 ted aw that's
video mayor requesting that this
proposal to people they remain static
tip gemenon on page 5 10 which is part
of the police's may report there were
two recommendations to this body the
rest on the fight to or what the
committee's agreed itself within these
terms of reference that's what the
committee is going to do but the
recommendations of this body around five
point 10 under 5 18 1 i'm a freak flag
down and that's reflected from yep came
to in a minute now I point out that
nevertheless the recommendation which is
to be found in Appendix B and on page 5
10 yeah is somewhat more concise as to
what we intend with respect to the our
quarterly update all their money up
David is not so prescriptive as the
previous recommendation yeah so this is
a more palatable one insofar as it
recommends a port to the update to the
point enforcement cases are presented to
the council so we're suggesting your
monthly update and it will contain what
information is available at that time
and not be pleasant rooted Germany right
if I may
I'm going to change tack again it's good
if I make on page 5.1 the first report
is about the review committees
consideration of planning enforcement
not Michelin's farm but planning
enforcement per se and the
recommendations on the to 2.1 on page
5.1 emanate from consideration of
planning enforcement per se the the next
report body 5.1 is about missions farm
yeah now when review committee looks of
that it went to stage further and that's
where the suggestion of a quarterly
updates a full council comes in and
because by the way that's word if it
would effectively be an update of all
enforcement cases not just missioning
yeah the executive at in terms of
clarification i understand the concept
of monthly reporting by the bulletin
that the next question is should there
also be quarterly reporting to full
council in addition to that monthly and
that would be around all enforcement
cases and and just to add that that's
what the and just to add the other
option would be to the development
committee in terms of governance I think
I taking in facility where each other
then we come back to you i'm t--exactly
design okay realistically as far as 2.1
section one which i think is what we're
referring to
okay I believe that wish the altering
that so it should be a monthly report
sell the content of which will be the
agenda within this report this draft
report as it stared at stuff and taken
exactly which will take into
consideration caseload case resolution
live cases notices planning
contravention notices planning
applications appearance of monitoring
compliance with enforcement notices
monitoring discharges conditions
prosecution's and call action licensing
consultations projects and those have
really town council adverts which will
be in there anyway but is this is energy
properties in conjunction with private
sector music we're actually putting a
lot more in this report that has
actually been required by the view and I
believe this is something but that we
should be going with because it gives a
full update to all members all members
monthly and as far as a quarterly report
I don't think as well as in bitterly
getting a very very point and putting it
on earth on all counts a report that the
same information actually the permit
necessities if there's any questions
that they wish to bring up bad council
about any of the reports which will be
there for them to look at they'll all be
numbered and dated then I should make
any questions referring to the date
number yeah I see no problem with that
members agreed on that sure what to come
so I shown you I was just good [ __ ]
chillin I think that it's a sort of
subject to that I was just going to make
the point that they're there for when
you get to 3.3 item to you I'd suggested
the executive
doesn't accept that recommendation on
the basis that you've dealt with that
yep that would be the portage what has
been said yes yeah okay our members
happy with that they don't clear nail I
hope then I thinks I'm so the minutes
whoever hopefully reflect their look you
thank you John Justin just the way the
point I don't believe this is an item
for four counts for anyway it's a quasi
judicial committee here and and not it's
not the right forum I bro you do as I
say I think members are going to be
fully informed absolutely remembers
bulletin full information available they
can go back to any of the planning
officers should they need to be towed
until the armed in what's going on in
there okay Chico I can't see a problem
with that okay right I think we're done
on that one thank goodness happen right
so this one is on the pilot immunity
vehicle scheme so there's not a lot of
discussion rumors but these members I'm
in your hands anybody want to say
anything good yes please your Thank You
chairman and for just say the
recommendation is there so I'm hoping
that how much really supports it is
something that our resident that into
the district use and use well and I'll
is about it and we have managed to get
the cost down it is still as it says a
pilot immunity vehicle scheme because
it's all depends on budgets and move
them forward okay me bunk I'm happy to
send back all right that's fine thank
you Sammy 1 i'm happy to seven good and
you all agreed group thank you what i
did take quite as long did it right so
members now we go into private
confidential I'll be able for